-Our next guest is a very
talented actress, comedian,
and cabaret performer you know
from shows such as
"Inside Amy Schumer"
and "Lady Dynamite."
She stars in the new comedy
series "Somebody Somewhere."
New episodes are available
Sundays on HBO and HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-Are we still going to be
tailing Rick then?
'Cause I have some stuff.
-No, he'll be
at my parents' house.
-Well, then, you're got to
be there.
-No, I have better things to do.
Saturdays are actually
pretty big for me.
-Oh, really?
You got like a Saturday ritual?
-I do.
-Oh.
-I like to sit down and write
out a list of goals for the week
and then, of course, I write
down a list of accomplishments
for the previous week
and stuff like that.
-Oh, my God. That's so amazing.
-Yeah.
I don't do any of that.
I like to lay around
drinking wine in my underwear.
-Oh.
-It's pretty [bleep] great.
-Hmm.
-Please welcome back to the show
Bridget Everett, everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome to the show.
How are you, Bridget?
-Great band.
You sound great, guys.
-They're wonderful.
You're wonderful.
Congratulations on the show.
-Thank you.
-I've heard you describe it as
a coming-of-middle-age story,
which is really a beautiful way
to describe it.
What was it like
working on the show?
What made you want to
work on this show?
-Well, HBO gave me a deal,
which was number one.
-That's a good start.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know.
Our writers, Paul and Hannah,
pitched this idea about a woman
who moves home to her hometown
to take care of her sister
who has now passed,
and then they have this thing
called choir practice,
which is like a fun, little
place where they all go sing.
And for me --
Sorry, I'm out of breath.
I just walked from here to here.
You guys don't know
what that's like.
[ Laughter ]
I literally -- In my apartment
I walk from the couch
to the bathroom, back to the
couch, to the liquor cabinet,
back to the couch,
back to the bathroom.
So that was a stretch.
Anyway, where were we?
The show, yeah.
-Yeah.
-The thing we're here
to talk about.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, so it's a woman,
she's just in her 40s,
kind of gliding through life,
and I can relate to that,
because I did that from
my late 20s to my mid-40s.
-So your journey in New York --
You became this very well-known
cabaret performer, but sort of
your first intro to performing
in New York was doing
karaoke nights at a club.
What was that like
and what were your songs?
And did right away you know,
"Oh, this is what
I should be doing"?
-Well, it was electric.
-Yeah. I bet it was electric.
-It was.
Because if there's something you
love doing and you can't do it
and the only place you can do it
happens to be at a karaoke bar,
you are going to go wild and
especially if you like alcohol.
[ Laughter ]
And your friend's a bartender.
My friend Alan used to just do
one of these
and then I'd sing "Piece of My
Heart" and "You Oughta Know,"
get up on the bar, rip open
my top and make some friends.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And then you brought
that sort of
take-no-prisoners approach
to your cabaret act.
You become very close with
audience members.
This is one of many photos
that really give a sense of
what you do on stage.
For those who can't tell
right now,
there's an audience member
beneath you.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Look, I think that
music and the arts
are about
connecting with people.
[ Laughter ]
And, you know, smiling
from the inside out.
[ Laughter ]
-So you were the youngest of
six, and -- There it is.
-I'm proud of myself.
-Yeah.
-I did that, and now I'm on HBO.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, I am wondering,
as the youngest of six,
you must know you're funny
when you can make
older siblings laugh.
-Well, okay.
I'm the youngest of six.
Bridget, Brock, Brian,
Brooke, Brad, Brenton.
And my family like has
one of those relentless
senses of humor, like, where
they make fun of each other
until someone cries.
And when you're the youngest,
that's you.
[ Laughter ]
So they used to call me Fang
'cause I had one front tooth,
and then they called me Lurch
'cause I had broad shoulders.
I was a talented swimmer.
You know,
from "The Addams Family."
Of course, you call me that on
the street, I'll cut you [bleep]
Thank you so much.
[ Laughter ]
-Family only.
That's family only.
I've also read that
part of this show
is a love letter to your mother.
Was she someone, growing up,
that made you laugh?
-My mom is, like, one of those
accidentally funny people.
You know, we grew up in Kansas,
and by the time she had me --
I'm the sixth kid --
she sort of just like,
didn't care anymore, right?
So we would go to the grocery
store in the dead of winter
and she would have like
a paper-thin nightgown on
with no bra, because why?
[ Laughter ]
She has these beautiful long --
now she just has one,
but before she had two --
these long, low-hanging [bleep]
we call beaver tails.
-Oh, beaver tails.
-So she was just beaver tails
about town.
[ Laughter ]
We would go into the Food 4 Less
and she's just like,
"Take a shopping cart
and go get yourself
some cereal and ice cream."
I would be like, "Okay."
And she would just go
flapping down the aisles.
[ Laughter ]
Living her best life.
-You have something that I think
is true for a lot of actors that
is maybe hard for people
to grasp, because I think
a lot of people assume the first
time they see you in a movie,
you've got it made.
-Yeah.
-But you were in
the "Sex and the City" movie.
So you were in a movie a lot of
people saw, but you were not --
At that point,
you were still waiting tables.
-Well, yeah. I did get a break.
I got to be in
the "Sex and the City" movie,
which was, you know,
a worldwide hit.
But luckily, I also got
the premium shifts
at my restaurant job,
just up the street
from Lincoln Plaza Cinemas,
where large groups of women
would go see it, and then they
would come to see us afterwards.
And they'd be like, "Oh, my God,
oh, my God.
You type like a mother[bleep]
right?
[ Laughter ]
I'm like, "That's me."
And they're like,
"Okay, now we'd like --"
you know, and then it was over.
So New York, you know, lifts you
up and then it spits you out
and kicks you down the stairs,
doesn't it?
-It certainly does.
One of the things that must be
fascinating about doing
a cabaret show in New York,
especially one that becomes
well-regarded,
you go into the audience
to interact with people.
And sometimes you might lay eyes
on famous faces.
Is it only in that moment, or
does someone backstage tell you
ahead of time, "Celebrity A, B,
and C are here"?
-Well, I usually know
who the famous people are
because they always wait until
the last minute to get tickets
and it's sold out, so I have to
give them my free tickets,
which isn't that funny.
-Yeah.
-Anyway, but this particular
night, one particular night,
I was walking around the
audience and there was a table
that was missing and I was,
you know, going around,
I was singing this song
about [bleep]
It's a love letter to my mom,
beaver tails and whatnot.
And I turn around and I'm
getting ready to make contact
with a new audience member,
and it's, like, boom,
and it's Gloria Steinem
and I'm like, "Cut the track!
Cut the track! Cut the track!
I'm not going to hug
Gloria Steinem with my [bleep]
We just met."
[ Laughter ]
But she loved it.
-She would've been into it.
-She was into it.
-There you go.
Hey, congratulations
on the show.
It's really wonderful.
It's got a wonderful cast.
And I can't wait
to see more of it.
Thanks so much for being here.
That's Bridget Everett!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-New episodes of "Somebody
Somewhere" are available
Sundays on HBO and HBO Max.
We'll be right back with more
"Late Night."